Man,
I am sick and tired of being treated
like I don't exist you to do whatever
you want to do whenever you want to do
it.
And I don't complain all the time.
So important about a dinner scene and
why would a director waste their time on
something so simple?
That's what we're going to focus on
today.
So welcome tonight.
Don't interrupt me.
We're done a drink.
I think dinner scenes are some of the
most powerful and revealing scenes in
the film.
They always show much more than people
eating.
They she'll communion.
When I say communion,
I mean an act of sharing and peace
between the people at the dinner table.
Directors use the dinner scene to show
us relationships between each character,
how they get along or how they don't.
I got to reply for you,
Andrew.
You think Carlton football's a joke.
Come play with us.
Four words you will never hear from the
NFL,
but I think even more is going on.
We all know the process of eating a
typical dinner you eat,
talk about your day,
make a few jokes and call it a night.
So when a meal goes wrong in a film,
we especially noticed because we're used
to dinners going a certain way and
that's what gives it dinner scene.
So much potential either for Kuma
or for drama.
I think that's funny,
Huh?
I think that's funny.
Let's look at what dinner scenes can
accomplish in three sections.
Humans eat the conflict and the
unexpected.
Whether you're a contract killer or a
demigod,
you have to eat and that makes you
human.
It was drawing [inaudible].
I know.
It's great,
right?
Showing characters,
eating makes them human like us.
It puts us into their world.
It makes us relate with them.
We can't relate to stealing.
Diamonds are getting shot,
but we can relate to getting in an
argument at the table.
Dinner scenes make us empathize with
characters.
Tarantino uses the dinner scene very
well and reservoir dogs and pulp fiction
to pull us into the world of his films.
When these characters who we just saw
have a friendly meal,
start getting shot and robbed the
restaurant,
it's that much more shocking because we
saw them as who they were people,
people who eat just like we do.
When people come together for dinner.
It's supposed to be a peaceful
communion,
but it doesn't always go that way.
Dinner scenes are perfect ways to show
conflict.
When people storm out,
Tom,
don't go there.
So my best friend,
okay,
Jesus,
wait dishes,
get left alone.
Not you know,
you'll be doing the dishes alone.
That says a lot about the characters
without having to tell us,
and so a successful meal means just the
opposite time.
Time to shove off moby and margie,
let me just simply,
no,
just
dinner doesn't always go smoothly.
It doesn't for us in real life and it
certainly doesn't for the characters in
a movie,
since we can relate to how awkward and
meal can be,
it can be much funnier when a dinner
scene doesn't go as expected.
I have no idea you could milk a cat.
Oh yeah,
you can milk anything with nipples.
I have nipples.
Greg,
could you milk me or it can be that much
more dramatic
to go from the familiar dinner scene to
an alien.
Busting out of somebody's chest really
adds to the horror
dinner.
That's just a dinner would be boring.
A director wouldn't waste to scene with
something as simple as people eating if
it wasn't to show something more
important.
That's what I love about film.
A film doesn't have to tell us
something.
It doesn't have to tell us,
this person doesn't get along with this
person or this person is human just like
you.
It can just show us,
hey Richard,
good to see you.
Showing rather than telling is what
makes a film go from good to great and
at dinner scene can be quite the show
and another thing from now on,
we're going to alternate our dinner
music because frankly,
and I don't think I'm alone here,
I'm really tired of this lawrence welk.
Shit.
Thanks for watching.